laurel hubbard will go to the olympics
carrying
so much more than a weight of
expectation
her very presence at the games is likely
to make her a flash point in a debate
that has become sport's most emotive
sensitive and complex issue
we do know that there are many questions
about fairness of transgender athletes
competing
in the olympic games but i would like to
take this opportunity to remind us all
that
morale has met all of the required
criteria
she is a very dedicated and resilient
athlete
hubbard lived for 35 years as a male and
did not compete
in international weightlifting
she transitioned in 2012 and has since
won several medals
and meets all of the ioc's requirements
some of her rivals say she will have an
unfair advantage in terms of physiology
and strength with belgium's anna van
bellingham claiming her presence would
be
like a bad joke for other competitors
even if laurel hubbard doesn't
win a medal they will have already taken
the slot of a woman
who would have got to the olympics a
woman who has trained all of her life
to get to the olympics so this idea that
the trans inclusion policy
is progressive and that it's inclusive
is wrong it's actually
an exclusionary policy but what does the
science say
biological males have significant
performance advantages over biological
females by virtue of
their exposure to testosterone and other
hormones during development
does lowering or suppressing
testosterone for 12 months or longer
remove typically male advantages and the
answer from
more than a dozen studies is a pretty
emphatic no
world rugby decided to ban transgender
women at international level
saying that it couldn't assure safety
and fairness for women competing against
trans women
in contact rugby laurel hubbard says she
is grateful and humbled to have been
selected for the games
where she will undoubtedly make history
and headlines
whatever the outcome of her event and
the brady sky news